طبعا في في وصف لهذا المشهد عند مدخل
الطوارئ في مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وهذا
العدد الكبير من جثامين الشهداء الذين
استشهدوا في الغارات التي استهدفت وسط
القطاع على وجه تحديد خلال الليله الماضيه
اي تحدي يمثله لكم استقبال هذا العدد من
الجثامين
والمصابين خلال ساعات
قليله
اختي الكريمه يوم امس كان يوم دامي مسلسل
مجازر
على المحافظه الوسطى ووصل الى مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى اكثر من 70 شهيدا جلهم
الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ تم استهدافهم في
مخيم المغازي
ومخيم
البريج كانوا هؤلاء المواطنين امنين في
اماكن سكناهم وعدد كبير منهم من النازحين
في مخيم المغازي كان يقنط احد البيوت التي
تم استهدافها
ويعني حوالي
65 مواطنا في داخل هذا البيت المكون من
اربع طوابق تم نسفه بالكامل لم ينجوا منه
سوى سته افراد ووصل 59 شهيدا من هذا
المنزل فقط
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وتم تدمير محيط
المسجد وهناك ما زال عدد كبير من الشهداء
والمصاب موجود تحت الركام وايضا في مخيم
البريج تم استهداف منزل عائله ابو حامده
ووصل اكثر من 35 شهيدا الان ارتفع عدد
الشهداء منذ ليله امس حتى هذه اللحظه
لاكثر من 95 شهيدا ومازال عدد كبير من
المصابين والشهداء موجود تحت الركام لم لم
يصل الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى بسبب عدم
وجود اليات لرفع الركام موجود في اماكن
الاستهداف ونهيك عن هذا ياتي في اطار
الاباده الجماعيه لابناء شعبنا في قطاع
غزه وسميت هذه المنطقه التي تم استهدافها
في مخيم المغازي بانها اماكن امنه يعني لا
يوجد مكان امن في قطاع غزه على الاطلاق
اذا كان في منزل واحد حوالي 55 شهيدا يتم
استهدافه يعني هناك حكم بالاعدام والاباده
الجماعيه لابناء ش في قطاع غزه وخاصه ان
هذه المنطقه منطقه مخيم المغازي تعتبر من
المناطق الامنه كما اعلن جيش الاحتلال
اختي الكريمه لا يوجد مكان امن على
الاطلاق في قطاع غزه يتم استهداف
المواطنين ويتم اعدامهم وهم امنين في
اماكن سكناهم ويتم استهداف جميع مكونات
الحياه في قطاع غزه يعني حتى الطواقم
الطبيه والصحفيين لم تسلم من القصف طائرات
الاحتلا ل وهناك ما زال
مسلسل المجازر مستمر معظم الشهداء الذين
وصلوا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وتم وضعهم
في اكياس تم عدد كبير من الشهداء الذين
وصلوا الى المستشفى مبتوري الرؤوس من
الاطفال ايضا ايضا وصل عدد كبير من
الشهداء وصل الى نصفين هناك عدد كبير كان
في صعوبه في التعرف عليه ونهيك على ان
ايضا وصل الى المستشفى يوم امس حوالي 190
اصابه وهذه الاعداد الكبيره نحن في مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى المستشفى الوحيد الموجود في
المحافظه الوسطى لا يستطيع استقبال مثل
هذه الاعداد الكبيره وخاصه ان المستشفى
ممتل عن بكره ابيه من الاصابات اختي
الكريمه لا نستطيع ان ان تضعي موضع قدم في
داخل المستشفى بسبب اعداد الاصابات
الخطيره والكبيره الموجوده والتي وصلت الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى هناك اعداد كبيره من
الاصابات تم وضعهم بين الاسره على الارض
وفي الممرات الداخليه والخارجيه حتى قسم
الاستقبال لا يوجد فيه سرير واحد ويتم
التعامل مع المصابين على الارض وحتى نقل
المصابين من سيارات الاسعاف الى داخل قسم
الاستقبال يتم على الواح من الخشب نهيك
على ان انهيار في المنظومه الصحيه في داخل
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى ومعظم مستشفيات شهداء
معظم مستشفيات قطاع غزه خرج الخ ط لا
تستطيع هذه المستشفيات تقم الاسعافات
الطبيه البسيطه فما بالك
بالعمليات والتدخلات الجراحيه المعقده
بالنسبه للمصابين تتحدث عن تكدس اعدادهم
داخل المستشفيات وفي مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
كيف تتصرفون حيال هذا الامر ما هو الحد
الادنى الذي يمكنكم تقديمه الان في هذه
المرحله نحن في مستشفى شهداء الاقصى نقوم
بالتعامل مع المصابين ب يعني بانقاذ
حياتهم بشكل متواضع جدا لعدم وجود
مستلزمات طبيه وادويه وكذلك هناك الاصابات
الخطيره ما زالت تنتظر امام قسم العمليات
ومنهم عدد كبير الليله فقد الحياه بسبب
عدم وجود يعني غرف عمليات لانقاذ هؤلاء
المصابين وايضا عدم وجود اماكن في اقسام
العنايه المكثفه خاصه ان العنايه الم
المكثفه امتل بالكامل لا يوجد اجهزه تنفس
صناعي في المستشفى كافيه لتعامل مع مثل
هذه الاصابات ولذلك نحن عبر قناتكم
الموقره نناشد العالم والمجتمع الدولي
والاحرار في العالم والمنظمات الدوليه
لفتح المعابر وتحويل الحالات المكتظه في
داخل مستشفيات قطاع غزه وارسال الادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه وارسال طواقم طبيه
لفتح مستشفيات ميدانيه في قطاع غزه لانقاذ
حياه هؤلاء المصابين اذا استمر هذا
الاغلاق ولم يتم تحويل الحالات ولم يتم
ارسال طواقم طبيه وادويه ستكون هناك يعني
مسلسل هناك حكم بالاعدام على مصابينا وعلى
مرضانا في في قطاع غزه نحن نناشد ونؤكد
العالم وناشدنا العالم منذ بدايه هذا
العدوان لوقف العدوان وارسال المستلزمات
الطبيه والادويه وارسال المواد الغذائيه
لان اختي الكريمه النازح حين باعداد كبيره
في داخل مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وفي اماكن
الاواء بجوار هذا المستشفى هناك انتقلت
الامراض المعديه بين النازحين والان اقسام
الاطفال امتلات بالكامل حتى تم وضع اكثر
من مريض من الاطفال على سرير واحد لان
انتشرت الامراض وخاصه النزلات المعويه
والتهاب الرهوي الرئوي الحاد وكذلك
الامراض الجلديه هناك وضع كارثه صحيه في
داخل مستشفى شهداء الاقصى وجميع مستشفيات
قطاع غزه لذلك وجب على العالم انقاذ حياه
هؤلاء المصابين وارسال ما يلزم ارساله
لقطاع غزه من الادويه والاغذيه
والمستلزمات الطبيه وحليب الاطفال الدكتور
خليل القران مدير قسم الطوارئ والمتحدث
باسم مستشفى شهداء الاقصى كنت معنا من
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح شكرا
جزيلا لك